guys this video and all of our videos
they're possible because of great
sponsors for this channel like Dollar
Shave Club if you want to support us
Dollar Shave Club is one of the easiest
and best ways that you can do that and
I'll only cost you five dollars now I
don't use Dollar Shave Club on my face
obviously but I do use it on my head and
it's fantastic I used to use those cheap
razors you know the kind of one or two
blade blue plastic horrible things that
you get in the store because I didn't
want to pay the super expensive prices
and I guess it kind of works when you're
doing your face maybe not very well but
at least you're not gonna cut yourself
horribly if you're shaving your head
Dollar Shave god it's even better than
when you're shaving your face which is
why it's perfect for me but it's you
know if you're just shaving your face
like a normal person you can grow hair
then that's fantastic
get Dollar Shave Club and he may see
anything about Dollar Shave Club is that
it is five dollars to get started and
basically what that means is that you
get amazing quality but it doesn't come
with a crazy price tag I mean like I
said no one wants to buy those super
crazy expensive razors that you get at
the store I still go in there and wonder
who buys that stuff so for that five
dollars you get an executive raise you
get three tubes of shaving stuff a scrub
shaving butter and a post shave do ya
they also have an oral kit and a shower
kit which are just five dollars each as
well the toothbrush is great I about my
previous one the bristles is that what
you call them we're all like this and
now I have a nice new one which is
fantastic it's a solid piece of kit
shower stuff is also great as well but
you know as a man with a lot of hair to
shave the razors are really where it is
at for me so if you're looking to get
started get the razors get the other
stuff if you want just go to
dollarshaveclub.com /vp and get started
for five dollars now if you thought
about supporting visual politic in some
way or another Dollar Shave Club is a
fantastic and easy way to do that let's
get into it shall we
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so the million-dollar question
why is Europe not growing I mean think
about it the European Union has the
second largest economy on the planet
just after the United States
nevertheless of the world's 50 largest
companies only eight come from European
soil
[Music]
while the New York Stock Exchange's on
fire European stock markets are going
down this includes Frankfurt Paris and
Madrid and what about the tech giants
we've all heard of Google Apple and
Amazon to name a few but what's there
EU equivalents well Germany has s AP
which is a database software company
Sweden has Spotify but let's face it
none of these are really a match for
Facebook or for uber and this is
especially worrisome if we consider the
entire world is on the rise yep
dear viewer if we take the GDP of all of
the countries on the planet including
the wealthy and the poor ones we have a
3.1 percent growth rate this is great
news for everybody but the Europeans
growth rate it hardly reaches 2.5
percent and believe me this is not good
for Europeans slower growth means less
jobs and less money for everybody at the
end of the day if an American or a
Chinese company can take on the market
sooner or later European firms will soon
go bankrupt so you know good luck
finding a well-paid job this is why many
politicians believe the EU has to bet on
bigger companies and it's in this
context that we found this headline from
the beginning of 2019 EU blocks Alstom
Siemens rail merger due to serious
competition concerns to summarize Alstom
is a French high-speed train
manufacturer have you ever seen those
French TJ vs those trains that appear in
movies like Mission Impossible well
those were manufactured by alstom
Siemens is on the other hands is a
German bear moth with a train
manufacturing division had they been
merged they would have become the second
largest train company on the planet
[Music]
and you might be wondering well what's
the first well of course that would be a
Chinese company so again Europe wants to
compete with China in terms of
technology so now you might be wondering
well why did they ban the merger this is
where we get to one of the oldest
economic dilemmas the foundation of free
markets is free competition this means
that if multiple companies compete for
customers they will end up offering
better goods and services at a lower
price now what happens when a company
becomes so large that it can smash the
rest well then we have a monopoly for
example let's say that Alstom and
siemens merged at this moment in time
the Spanish government wants to buy new
high-speed trains well if there's only
one company capable of meeting these
high standards well why would that
company lower their price at the end of
the day they're the only choice on
European soil and that's at all if this
company could take all the contracts
well what would be the incentive for
other entrepreneurs to compete in the
Train industry in other words it would
be the opposite of a free market on the
other hand we can argue that if two
companies want to merge who is the EU to
say no to that that doesn't sound like a
very free-market thing either
[Music]
as you can see this is a bit of a
dilemma it's also one of the biggest
ideological debates of our time this is
not the classical fight between
socialism versus capitalism in fact we
can say that this is a fight between two
different views on capitalism we're
gonna say that this is French capitalism
versus German capitalism so now the
question is what was it a good idea to
block the Siemens Alstom merger then
what's the difference between French and
German capitalism and does Europe really
need these big companies well today we
are going to answer all of these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history
French capitalism versus German
capitalism if you've been following
visual politics for a long time you
might remember this video that we made
about France France is a country famous
for croissants baguettes and economic to
reach ISM since the times of Chartres
gall French capitalism has worked like
an army
of course they have private companies
and somehow competition among them but
for decades the French economic playbook
said that the government's must help and
promote their big corporations this is
why starting a company in this country
can be as hard as you could imagine but
hey if you're a big company while the
state's gonna roll out the red carpet
for you if I could you remember this
list with the world's 50 biggest
companies so from those 80 European
companies and three are French and this
is not by chance
german capitalism it's the opposite of
course germany has regulations and taxes
but the aim of those is to protect a
greater good the environment labor
rights or competition how about an
example let's talk about economic policy
if you remember in this other video we
explained how Germany is totally against
nuclear power and how they're closing
all of their plants
this means that producing energy in this
country is very expensive but on the
other hand no other country relies more
on nuclear plants than France does
theoretically this would mean that the
energy bills here should be way cheaper
than those in Germany right well
actually not at all if you check out
expat Aston calm you'll see that if you
lived in Paris you would pay about the
same as living in Munich which is one of
the most expensive German cities why
well because of things like this french
consumer groups is EDF monopoly boosts
power prices
the truth is Germany has a lot of energy
companies competing on the same playing
field nobody has the government as a
shareholder all right so there is
actually a small exception here which
would be Eon but we're talking only
about 2% of the capital held by a
regional government the rest of the
companies they're fully state free they
also have no privileges whatsoever
France though that's a different animal
here they have a big fair mouth called
EDF 70 percent of their capital is owned
by the French government
this means a big helping hands from the
government in almost monopolistic
conditions of course it's not all bad
thanks to its public support EDF is the
world's third largest company in their
industry they've also got a big foothold
in other countries including African
ones the price of having such a big
company that's paid for by the French
consumers the same goes for other
industries as well for example
automobiles
France has to juggernauts Reynaud and
Fujio acetone that got merged some years
ago many of you might think that these
are horrible companies that compete on
free market right well this isn't quite
the case
see in both cases the French government
is one of the main shareholders Marino's
case the French government owns 15% of
the company
this means a nice little financial
cushion for Reynaud coming straight from
the taxpayers pocket thanks to this
renault starts from an advantageous
position compared with other car makers
but not only that having so many shares
the government can intervene directly in
the company's affairs for example paris
would never allow renault to fall into
foreign hands many times the government
is vetoed the closure of factories or is
given grants to develop new car models
so well now let's hop over and have a
look at what happened in germany in this
case the german government has no stocks
in any car maker BMW for example is
completely in private hands
Volkswagen they're partially owned by a
city hall but it's completely
independent from the central government
this means that Germany doesn't help any
of their companies at least in theory
and something similar happens in the
Nordic countries this is why we can find
headlines like this one ely holding
pleats acquisition of shares in a b
Volvo in this case Volvo is one of the
biggest companies in Sweden and Geney
Holdings is a Chinese group the Swedish
government did nothing to stop this
acquisition but good luck trying to do
the same thing in France it's not that
they have lots of regulations against
foreign investment it's just that the
fact that if Volvo were French they
would be surely owned by the governments
and the government let that happen but
if you want to see French versus German
capitalism in action well pay attention
to today's story let's have a look
[Music]
juggernaut on Rails by the way this
amazing tune you're listening to now is
from hard bone a German hard rock fans
that sent us their music
[Music]
the zone we're playing right now is
cooled no-man's land there was a time
when China was a corporate no-man's land
the country was growing like gangbusters
they needed roads bridges and trains
they didn't have companies to build
those this is why in 2004 it signed a
big contract with Siemens to build
high-speed trains the Chinese can
negotiate like nobody else one of the
conditions was that next to the German
engineers there would be Chinese ones
learning from them so well what was the
conclusion Chinese people learned how to
make high-speed trains no surprise years
later Siemens ended the contract and
China got what they wanted technology
with this technology they created their
own company see our RC and this was not
a normal company it soon became the
biggest company in its industry
worldwide see ah see the Chinese rail
juggernaut Europe is afraid of the
corporation brought in about 26 billion
euros in revenue in 2017 and size really
matters in the corporate world with all
this money you see RC can make big
investments and smash their competitors
they've already won big contracts in
America Serbia and the Czech Republic so
what does a French person think when
they face a foreign competitor well they
think this Germany Siemens
Frances Austin emerged to create new
European rail champion the new company
was meant to be the second largest in
the world and you might wonder well
where did they used to have their
headquarters and oh what a question well
obviously it's in Paris I mean where
else so everybody was happy the
shareholders the French government and
also the German governments yep in this
story the German government was pretty
much in agreement with the French one so
well where is the problem the problem
was in the antitrust laws basically if
two big companies merge they need
special authorisation in Europe the
limit to determine what is big and what
is not is five billion euros of gross
income and 250 million euros in income
within Europe if the company that comes
out of the merger surpasses those limits
then they need to ask for permission
from the European Commission which is
sort of the executive power in Europe
and this is where our friends from
Alstom Siemens had to face this woman
Marguerite for Sega also known as the
trust Buster vestige IRS's no to Siemens
Alstom mega merger is the EU
commissioner for competition something
like the Minister for regulating big
corporations it is my being Danish we
can see that vesta in this story
represents german capitalism her
argument was that Alstom Siemens would
be big enough to smash the small
competitors don't forget that we're
talking about the very political
industry where most of the contracts are
paid for by different governments so
imagine who would win all of the public
contracts in Germany and France and well
this is where the big dilemma started
[Applause]
French economy minister Bruno Lima has
vividly defended the intended merger
between European train manufacturers
Alstom France and Siemens Germany the EU
refusing a merger would be a big
economical and political mistake as you
can imagine both the French and German
governments had been lobbying in
Brussels as much as they could in order
to make this merger happen their train
of thought was that the Chinese might
end up manufacturing all of the European
trains
festa instead insisted that the best way
to face Chinese competitors is with
innovation and the best way to boost
innovation is to have lots of smaller
companies competing with each other so
now the question goes to you what would
you have done would you have accepted
the Alstom Siemens merger do you think
that Europe needs to create big
corporate juggernauts to face foreign
competition well please leave your
answer in the comment section below also
please do visit offerings reconsider
mediacom the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode but well not mine
also please do subscribe we have brand
new videos every week and hit that Bell
button to find out about them also like
I said Dollar Shave Club are the sponsor
behind today's video it would be
fantastic if you could support us by
supporting them it's just $5 to get
started just go to dollarshaveclub.com
/vp and as always i'll see you next time